[Music]
this video is sponsored by Best Buy hey
what's up I'm kimbhd here coming at you
from the new basement home studio so I
remember a couple years ago I think it
was I was approached or I was asked to
take a look at these like 30 million
dollar New York City skyscraper
Apartments just like maybe it could be a
cool video I thought yeah maybe I'll
check it out that maybe there's some
cool Tech in these spaces like there's
got to be something cool for 30 million
dollars right and it turns out nope not
really there was I think one of them had
like a an iPad Mini bolted to the wall
with like light switches or smart Shades
or something like that but it wasn't
that much basically what I'm saying is
the Smart Homes of the future that we
were hoping maybe we'd have by now
mostly don't really exist yet
um I did a whole retro Tech episode
about that but there is some smart home
Tech around here that I do actually use
now so welcome to my current basement
studio in progress I'm going to be
working on this as it gets better over
time but this is a Smart Home Tech that
I currently use right now and honestly
I'm hoping this list also improves over
time this is just the stuff that I've
gotten to work in this home and I'm
gonna walk through it all now there is
some stuff that is actually more baked
into the home itself like I shared
recently on Twitter about getting my
first zero dollar electricity bill now
that I have solar on my roof which is
pretty incredible maybe leave a thumbs
up for that if you're interested in a
separate video on that but for now this
one's about like the gadgets like the
tangible physical stuff you could pick
up today in a smart home now I realize
some of you might be expecting that I
have some sort of like crazy super high
virtualized crazy smart home thing with
like robot vacuums everywhere and smart
home stuff all over the place and I kind
of don't like I kept it pretty simple I
do have mostly regular light bulbs
everywhere I have one set of smart
lights which I'm going to show you but
really the choice at the beginning for
me was what ecosystem do I want to jump
in you sort of have to set up everything
in one place and so the choices would be
Google's it would be apples or it would
be Amazon's with Alexa and I chose
Google's just no regrets so far my main
phone is typically an Android phone I
like and use Google Assistant all the
time and so that's just where I started
by making sure everything would be
compatible with Google home so many of
you may remember Google bought Nest the
downside of Google buying Nest is the
nest app was amazing but now all these
new things pretty much require the
Google home app which is missing a
couple of those features so it's slowly
gotten better over time and I'm still
hoping they can add things like the
ability to pair some older Nest products
and temperature sensors Etc and the
ability to see and adjust the nest
thermostat's temperature schedule I'm
hoping this will come in future versions
so I can make the most of this Nest
Hardware all on a single app but for now
yeah Google ecosystem means Google home
app so most of the tech live is actually
down here in this little basement studio
and that's where I have the Hub over
here which is the Google Google Nest Hub
Max so just like the home app on my
phone this is where I control you know
all the lights ask assistant for things
view the doorbell camera when somebody
Rings it Etc I've had this guy for a few
years and it's been Rock Solid then the
first big thing that this talks to that
I have is Nest thermostats these are
already like the most popular things
ever you've probably most likely already
heard of them they learn your habits
they let you set schedules so it saves
energy by not running things as much
when you're away and then cooling down
or heating up the house for you as you
get home I have this working hand in
hand with my solar and Battery setup it
is super handy but also Nest isn't just
a good looking smart home thermostat it
also has Nest renew which looks at the
cleanliness of the power coming into
your home it helps optimize for pulling
the cleanest power anytime you actually
do pull from the grid which for me with
solar is a little more rare but then
next up I also have a smart doorbell
this one's more new to me so this is a
Google Nest doorbell battery it's super
for Handy it's got good camera quality a
wide enough angle that you can see the
ground so anytime there's packages it
gives me an alert for those and it talks
to the app and the nest Hub Max no
problem so if a delivery person's at the
door and I'm not home I can just tell
them through the microphone to leave the
package I've done that a few times and
then it lets you specifically set your
zones for where it should look to send
you notifications so you don't get tons
of unnecessary ones from cars driving by
or things like that all the classic
features you'd want from a smart
doorbell now as a heads up for me so
there is battery charging required with
this one and I've been getting only
maybe three weeks or so on a charge even
after playing around with the settings
to get less notifications now on their
site they're saying even if you're busy
it should last at least a month luckily
it's easy to pop off the door and plug
into USBC charge a few hours and then
you're back in business of course you
could always just get a hardwired
version to avoid this altogether but I
cover all the other points of Entry here
with Google cameras so indoor camera and
outdoor camera with floodlights nothing
too special about these other than they
are of course working in the Google home
app they're basically versions of the
nest doorbell without the doorbell so
they're high quality cameras smart
alerts a recognized set of faces and
again they let you draw smart zones for
where to notify you of certain movements
and then the last thing on the outside
you can get a Smart Lock installed on
pretty much any door you want so I chose
this Yale Smart Lock which is as simple
as it looks it's an Internet connected
passcode lock and it's awesome that
you're able to know that the door is
locked from wherever you are and you can
lock it if it's not locked if you're
ever not sure so that's a piece of Mind
win for me now uh smart lights as far as
those I have two in the basement here
and these are Philip Hughes lamps these
are on the pricey side but I got them
because so there's only one light in the
middle of this room so when I'm at the
computer and the webcam is pointing at
me I'm basically backlit by this one
light so I have one pointed at the wall
over here just to brighten up on my face
which is nice and then the other ones
over here here pointing at the wall to
brighten up the rest of the room so
instead of getting more lights installed
I just got them pointed at the wall I
kind of like pointing lights at the wall
now the Philips Hue app also has these
intricate scenes and effects for example
there's a candle effect or a fireplace
effect which does actually work it
changes the mood of the whole room but I
typically don't use these very much
again it's nice knowing that they're
Internet connected so I can change
things from afar remotely with the app I
think my next upgrade will be adding a
smart light switch in this room so I
don't have to open the app every time I
walk in the room I want to turn the
lights on I just walk in and hit the
light switch like any other normal light
but anyway tying it all together you
gotta have internet around the place for
it to be smart home so I was previously
using Google assistant so they have
these little pods that double actually
as assistant so they have a microphone
in them you can just ask them anything
anywhere I was using that before but
with the walls of this house and the way
it's laid out I was not getting the
speeds I wanted so I did some research
and read a lot of reviews and eventually
that's how I found these monstrosities
here these things are netgear's Wi-Fi
mesh system the link is below now these
are a lot bigger and a lot less friendly
looking so hopefully you have somewhere
to hide them but the average speeds I
have now across my house have literally
tripled so I see why the reviews are so
good and I'm definitely keeping them and
then here's the last somewhat
interesting piece of Hardware it's a
smart plug so I had to look this up
because I'd had this for so long but
this is the casa Smart Wi-Fi plug pretty
simple basically you set it up once it's
got its own app and then it shows up in
the Google home app and then it's a
Smart Wi-Fi plug so if you want to turn
a normal lamp into a smart lamp like
I've done easy or if you want to turn
the Christmas tree on and off
automatically for the month of December
it's perfect for that and it's cheap so
yeah once that's all set up the fun part
is like really setting up everything to
work for you that's kind of what I've
done in Google land the version of a
bunch of things working under one
command is called routine so in the app
you can string together a bunch of tasks
into one command so when I say hey G how
is my day in the morning that's how I
start the day it reads off the weather
it shows me what's on my calendar for
the day it tells me my phone's battery
percentage in case I forgot to charge it
fires up the news for the day tells me
the traffic on the way to the studio and
opens up all the smart Shades upstairs
it's not much but it's pretty convenient
to me I I have this thing where I like
to not touch my phone first thing in the
morning I actually highly recommend
trying this I get up feet touch the
ground walk away from my bed without
touching my phone so it's kind of nice
to just ask Google what's going on with
my day as I'm going through the morning
routine and not sit there scrolling on
my phone that's why I start my day oh a
side note I also didn't I forgot to
mention Sonos beam and sonos's uh
subwoofer best sounding speakers I've
ever heard at least in my own house and
they also do work with Google Assistant
which is a nice bonus but anyway that's
my current smart home stuff coming out
you live from the half empty being built
currently basement Studio maybe some of
this is inspirational for you if you're
setting up some of the smart home stuff
for the first time but also this is the
type of video where I know I'm going to
get better suggestions I'm going to get
some ideas from the comments so you guys
leave on this video for stuff that I can
do in the future down here and we'll
keep this updated we'll keep this posted
and I'll actually be doing more videos
from here once I finish getting it set
up so yeah that's pretty much it shout
out again to Best Buy for sponsoring
this video everything that I mentioned
in the video can be purchased on Best
Buy so all the links are below like I
mentioned and I'll talk to you guys in
the next one base
[Music]